[Musique]
une petite route de l'arizona dans le
sud-ouest des etats-unis jim est
persuadé que l'apocalypse est pour
bientôt et il se prépare activement pour
y survivre
personne ne doit savoir où nous rendons
je porte un masque et je garde ma
planche secrète comme ça en cas de crise
je n'aurai pas à redouter les pillards
là je vous emmène dans un endroit prévu
pour se retrancher dans la pire des
situations
c'est très isolés ici et on ne sait
jamais sur quoi on peut tomber quand on
monte par là après avoir arpenté toute
la région
jim a repéré ici il y a quelques années
un refuge en prévision de la catastrophe
qu'il redoute
si j'ai choisi cet endroit c'est parce
que c'est de la bonne roche bien solide
là ce sera l'entrée et moi je serai
dedans tout au fond il vient
régulièrement vérifier que l'entrée des
boyaux souterrains de cette ancienne
mine d'or reste accessible
il y aura un gros déluge des
raz-de-marée des tremblements de terre
tout un tas de désastre qui vont balayer
une bonne partie de la population
je me considère vraiment comme un de
ceux qui survivront j'aime cette idée
ce sont les meilleurs qui restent non je
plaisante jim est fin prêt pour son
scénario catastrophe
un scénario que nous avons tous pu voir
récemment au cinéma
car derrière on regarde moi j'ai l'air
d'avoir par les chutes de météorites
tremblement de terre cataclysme en série
le film 2012 a été un grand succès dans
le monde entier
c'est la fin du monde un alignement
inédits des planètes provoquerait la
catastrophe
l'histoire est basée sur une ancienne
prophétie maya qui n'a aucun secret pour
jim
les prophéties sur 2012 et les
prophéties des indiens hopis indique que
c'est dans cette région qu'ont sera le
plus à l'abri et comme vous voyez ici il
peut arriver des millions de mètres
cubes d'eau sans que l'on soit menacé on
sait jamais peut-être qu'il me faudra
construire une arche gym pourrait passer
pour un farfelu isolé mais en réalité il
est loin d'être seul un simple coup
d'oeil sur internet permet de le
vérifier
aux etats unis ils sont des milliers
comme lui à s'exprimer sur des dizaines
de sites tous persuadés que la fin du
monde est pour dans trois ans le 21
décembre 2012
exactement il ya même un compte à
rebours qui indique le nombre de jours
qui nous restent à vivre
[Musique]
on s'en sortir
il ne suffit pas d'avoir un refuge
secret il faut aussi posséder toute la
panoplie du parfait survivants à phoenix
la cinquième ville des états-unis jim
notre survie gens masqués à un ami
dennis qui lui fournit tout son attirail
de survie ça c'est le paquetage urgence
avec tout ce qu'il faut on le prend et
on se sauve
[Musique]
dennis van par correspondance toutes
sortes d'articles pour survivre du sac à
dos aux compléments alimentaires en
passant par les couteaux suisses les
boussoles les talkie walkie ou les
appareils de positionnement gps ça c'est
un briquet d'urgence un truc que j'aime
bien garder tout le temps sur moi la
secouer ça marche tout seul comme ça
dennis sauf sur la notoriété du film
2012 pour vendre ses produits sur son
site internet
l'idée de ce business lui est venue lors
de la dernière catastrophe annoncée
le fameux passage à l'an 2000 en 1999 je
travaillais pour un grand magasin de
bricolage
on craignait le bug de l'an 2000 et on
s'est retrouvés en rupture de stock de
groupes électrogènes
je me suis dit la prochaine fois qu'un
événement pareil doit se produire
je dois être celui qui en tirera profit
dennis a plaqué un bon job pour monter
son affaire
et ça marche en trois ans il est parvenu
à gagner largement de quoi faire vivre
sa famille de deux enfants 2012 une
source de profits pour lui mais aussi
une vraie conviction personnelle j'ai
amélioré mes connaissances et ma
clairvoyance au cas où j'en aurai besoin
en 2012
ça a complètement changé ma vie on a des
réserves de nourriture
de quoi cuisiner de l'éclairage une
trousse de premiers soins et des masques
à gaz
de nice a même entraîné ses enfants à
respirer dans un masque à gaz
après la catastrophe il faudra bien
repeupler la planète avec les survivants
pas d'inquiétude jim et dennis ont tout
prévu
ils ont déniché le site idéal à 200
kilomètres de chez eux en cas
d'embouteillage et de panique générale
ils savent qu'ils pourront même coupé
par cette petite route de service je
suis vraiment inquiet à cause des
émeutes de la panique des gens qui
n'auront rien préparé et je serai
peut-être obligé de me battre pour
arriver là haut donc j'ai prévu un plan
appuie un plan b est ce que je souhaite
que ça arrive non est ce que je suis
prêt oui à 2000 mètres d'altitude
jim a acheté ce terrain de plusieurs
dizaines d'hectares avantage il n'y a
qu'une seule route d'accès et la
situation permet de surveiller toute la
vallée
c'est ici qu'il rebâtirons la
civilisation avec les quelques familles
qui l'ont déjà recruté sur internet
allez faut qu'on déplace tout ça là
depuis plusieurs années jim accumule ici
tout un tas d'objets hétéroclites qui
pourrait s'avérer très utile dans trois
ans ça ce sont des matériaux de
construction dont j'aurai besoin
avec ce que j'ai là je peux construire
une maison entière
on a dégagé des terrains pour que les
familles amènent leur matériel et se
réinstalle ça dépendra de ce qu'ils ont
à offrir
parce que l'important c'est qu'on ne
veut pas de ceux qui n'auront rien ni
provisions de savoir faire il mettrait
la communauté en danger la fin du monde
une peur aussi ancienne que l'humanité
mais ces dernières années le mouvement
prend de plus en plus d'ampleur alimenté
par les crises majeures attaque
terroriste conflit armé crise financière
risque d'épidémie mondiale ouragans
cyclones dérèglement climatique
la menace semble venir de partout
les fantasmes paranoïaque s'emballe à
hollywood les films catastrophes s'en
inspire et nous rappellent régulièrement
que la planète est en sursis
la dernière tendance c'est de nous
montrer comment les hommes peuvent
survivre après une catastrophe majeure
comme dans la route un film qui raconte
l'errance d'un père et de son fils dans
une amérique dévastée
tu crois qu'il ya encore combien de
personnes en vie un monde avoue cran
tout juste sorti sur les écrans
le livre d'eli ressuscite la vieille
angoisses du cataclysme nucléaire les
attentes en la guerre provoque un trou
dans le ciel cette croyance en la fin du
monde porte un nom le survivalisme une
tendance qui est en train de devenir un
mouvement d'opinion
joël secousse n en est l'un des
principaux théoriciens il ne croit pas
aux prophéties mayas sur 2012 mais
craint des dangers beaucoup plus concret
le film 2012 a créé des peurs qui amène
des gens vers le mouvement survivalistes
mais il ya d'autres menaces plus
réalistes les révoltes sociales qui vont
accompagner la crise et surtout à long
terme
le péril qui m'inquiète le plus c'est
celui d'une guerre contre la russie et
la chine
[Musique]
là j'ai fait une projection de la
manière dont les réactions de panique
vont se répandre à partir des sites
ciblés par les attaques nucléaires
survivre en 10 leçons comment protéger
sa maison ou encore le guide des
endroits les plus sûrs aux états unis
joël secoue scène publie des livres très
pratique et il est devenu un consultant
très écouté son conseil numéro un
vivre loin des zones de forte population
là c'est ce que je considère comme la
zone la plus sûre des états unis les
montagnes de l'ouest
l'altitude est élevée il y fait froid en
hiver les gens du sud n'aime pas le
froid et ne viendront donc pas par ici
et c'est entourée de désert ce qui rend
la zone difficile d'accès aux autres
populations voisines
le coeur de cette zone la plus sûre des
états unis c'est l'utah ici dans la
vallée de sainte pitt
il existe déjà une communauté de
survivalistes ils ont quitté la ville il
y a vingt ans pour créer le ranch de la
liberté
l'accès est interdit aux curieux
une quarantaine d'habitants y vivent en
autarcie dans une dizaine de maisons
isolées et autosuffisante en eau et en
énergie
ils sont coupés du monde et aucun de ces
futurs survivant n'a accepté de nous
recevoir
à l'exception du dernier arrivé sterling
allan a choisi de se réfugier dans cette
vallée avec sa famille il y a quelques
mois
inspiré par des prédictions locale j'ai
passé toute ma vie à me préparer à ces
choses toute ma vie d'adulte
il y aura des poches de survivants à
travers le monde
les gens appellent cela les sites et de
lumière il y à quelques légendes ou
prophétie qui cite la sente pitt valais
comme un endroit de regroupement une
zone de sécurité des gens qui ont eu des
visions de la vallée entièrement remplie
de tentes avec des gens venus comme des
réfugiés des destructions des villes la
samp il valait deviendrait alors le
sanctuaire des survivants et sterling a
déjà pensé à la manière de le défendre
ce serait bien de pouvoir surveiller les
entrées et d'avoir des guetteurs pour
les pillards parce que les rôdeurs
viendront quand les choses vont se gâter
être nombreux cela permet d'avoir des
sentinelles la nuit pour lancer l'
alerte
c'est facile aussi d'isoler complètement
la vallée avec un petit peu de dynamite
on peut en bloquer les accès sterling
prépare déjà toute sa famille à survivre
à un futur incertain et il en a même
fait son métier
il est ingénieur et dessine des maisons
autonome qui consomment le minimum
d'énergie
on essaie de combiner l'écologie avec
l'esthétique et le confort un
désavantage de préparer les choses avant
que tout s'écroule c'est que l'on pourra
la vivre mieux une fois que ce sera
arrivé plutôt que de vivre dans des
tentes ou dans des cartons ça ne risque
pas d'être très marrant après le grand
cataclysme pour suivre sa logique il a
décidé de ne plus envoyer ses enfants à
l'école suis simplement ses traits là
c'est bien
c'est sa femme chérie qui leur fait la
classe à la maison un choix courant chez
les survivalistes car ils n'ont aucune
confiance dans les institutions
publiques comme l'école où le
gouvernement
ils tiennent à rester à l'écart du reste
de la société car il considère que notre
civilisation a déjà commencé à sombrer
ce dont j'ai plus peur c'est c'est que
notre pays s'effondre et que des guerres
civiles arrive que le gouvernement n'est
pas le contrôle de la situation
que les gens se mettent à se battre pour
la nourriture ce genre de choses à
l'abri dans leur communauté
ces futurs survivants ne sont pas seuls
à avoir choisi de s'installer
précisément ici à moins d'un kilomètre
de là dans la même vallée paul seyfried
a trouvé la solution à toute épreuve
l'assurance survie clé en main pour la
fin du monde et ce aux arts ça c'est
l'entrée est en fait tout va bien
tout va bien
dans le film la route les héros découvre
cet abri souterrain qui va leur sauver
la vie
c'est quoi tu joues tu sais ce type
d'abri que construit paul seyfried la
saison plus grand modèle
un cylindre en zinc de 15 mètres de long
ensevelie à quatre mètres sous terre
c'est assez comparable un sous-marin de
la seconde guerre mondiale très spacieux
pour chacun mais un peu plus confortable
paul est ingénieur dans la construction
aéronautique
les abris c'est son deuxième boulot il a
tout prévu même les radios à ondes
courtes pour communiquer avec les autres
survivants ou bien des compteurs de
radiation nucléaire est un système
d'aération filtrer et qui peut
fonctionner manuellement
[Musique]
chaque personne la place pour ranger ses
affaires
[Musique]
et ça c'est le dortoir des retardataires
il a de quoi tenir pendant six mois pour
5 personnes sans mettre le nez dehors à
l'abri des tremblements de terre des
tornades des cyclones ou même d'une
troisième guerre mondiale
pour paul chaque foyer américain devrait
avoir un tel refuge plupart des gens sur
la planète refuse de voir que l'on court
à la catastrophe technologique pas
compte que le temps d'une pause déjeuner
à l'autre bout du monde qu'ils soient
des gens peuvent appuyer sur un bouton
et lancé des milliers de têtes
nucléaires sur les états unis
cela fait 25 ans que paul construit ces
abris à travers les états unis et en a
vendu 300 à 30000 euros pièce et à
chaque crise majeure son business
d'école une chose est sûre si en 2012 il
n'en reste qu'un jim notre survivants
masqué est certain d'être celui-là si
2012 arrive et que le 1er janvier je
suis assis là en vacances c'est qu'il ne
s'est rien passé
j'aurai toujours à m'inquiéter pour le 2
janvier puis pour le 3 et pour ce qui
risque d'arriver encore après d'après
les survivalistes il ne reste qu'un peu
plus de 1000 jours avant la fin du monde
mais selon les scientifiques la planète
terre encore 5,2 milliards d'années
devant elle sauf accident